le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
avoir un logement décent à la Réunion à
notre époque semble tout à fait normal
et courant mais malheureusement
certaines personnes vivent dans des
habitations anciennes et des labrées
personne âgées personne à mobilité
réduite retraite insuffisante handicap
important ces facteurs qui amènent bien
souvent des citoyens vulnérables dans
des conditions de vie inacceptables
certains logements sont parfois si
dégradés qu'ils sont dangereux pour les
personnes qui y vivent alors vers qui se
tourner pour y trouver de l'aide on en
parle maintenant dans le lien social
Elisabeth vit à la possession depuis de
très nombreuses années cela fait
maintenant 18 ans qu'elle habite ici
dans cette maison
seul avec une petite retraite et à un
âge assez avancé elle s'est retrouvée au
fil du temps avec une maison très abîmée
les soirs de pluie s'en inquiétude l'eau
qui rentrait par le toit au risque de
créer des courts-circuits et à chaque
pas elle risque de glisser chuter et se
blesser
comme Elisabeth des centaines de foyers
réunionnais trouvent un soutien auprès
du Conseil Général pour réaliser des
travaux nécessaires à certaines
habitations sans ces aides encore trop
de personnes pourraient continuer de
vivre dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires
comme vous savez les politiques liés au
logement sont des politiques qui ont
principalement de la compétence de
l'État cependant le Conseil général a
voulu se positionner sur l'aide à
l'amélioration des habitations
individuelles des personnes qui l'a
aussi sont en dessous d'un certain
niveau de revenus et c'est ainsi que nos
consacrons tous les ans 25 millions
d'euros de crédit qui touchent à peu
près 2000 logements et qui font
travailler plusieurs centaines
d'artisans au travers de quatre
opérateurs nous avons et aussi nous
intervenons aussi pour permettre des
dépenses d'accessibilité pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite donc nous
peuvent nous pouvons modifier une salle
de bain on fait une rampe d'accès en ce
sens dans notre politique d'amélioration
habitat touche des personnes qui en ont
véritablement besoin où est-il volonté
sur conseil général dont nous sommes
assez fiers les aides à la nationalité
touchent un public
prioritaire pour nous ce sont des
personnes fragilisées par leur âge pour
leur situation de handicap au parc des
conditions de vie très pénibles et qui
bien évidemment ont des ressources
inférieures à un certain plafond et qui
nécessite une aide publique grâce à
l'aide du Conseil Général Elisabeth et
bien d'autres réunionnais peuvent
aujourd'hui vivre dans des conditions
sanitaires et digne de notre société
l'habitat et le logement sont
normalement de la compétence de l'État
mais le département tient aussi à
participer et soutenir les Réunionnais
dans ce secteur une démarche
volontariste preuve que le Conseil
général est bien aux côtés des
Réunionnais le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général aux côtés des
Réunionnais